if you're a fan of big movies you've
probably got a neatly organized laundry
list of films to catch this year from
Star Wars the last Jedi to Wonder Woman
all the big flicks you won't want to
miss are committed to your memory but
with all that focus on blockbusters a
ton of amazing picks may have slipped
under your radar here are some of the
underappreciated movie gems from 2017
that you just need to add to your list
and watch as soon as possible for girl
with all the gifts the zombie genre has
been crowded for decades and in the post
Walking Dead era it's only growing more
popular it's hard to come up with a new
spin on those shambling undead tropes
but the girl with all the gifts somehow
manages to do it anyway
adapted from mr Carrie's novel the story
imagines a world in which much of the
human population has been wiped out by a
fungus porn zombie plague yes just like
in the video game The Last of Us but in
the girl with all the gifts a second
generation victims retain their human
characteristics even as they are
consumed by a hunger for flesh instead
of turning into one of these Oh No the
nightmares are gonna come back in the
girl with all the gifts which saw a
limited release in the u.s. early in the
year the surface level humanity poses a
moral conundrum for a teacher tasked
with educating the so called Hungary's
and that's compounded by the harsh
utilitarian views of the doctor in
command played by Glenn Close like the
best zombie horror of a girl with all
the gifts as underlined with
thought-provoking and existential
questions about modern society and human
nature and it's also an insane thrill
ride the red turtle sweeping and
life-affirming this film is by Studio
Ghibli yup the same studio that made my
neighbor totoro the red turtle doesn't
have a single sentence of dialogue and
the VATS gives it a pinprick intensity
that'll keep your eyes glued to the
screen the entire time the movie centers
around an unnamed man shipwrecked on a
deserted tropical island who later
encounters a giant red turtle but it's
far more than what it seems
superficially it dives deep into the
tenderness and tribulations of what it
means to be human
recounting milestones and memory mark
has set over gorgeous animated design
aesthetics and an incredible score while
our nameless
were set adrift by a storm we follow
along the moving plot an engrossing
layout until we're turned inside out at
the film's climax one that builds and
bursts without warning the red turtle is
truly an experience it's utterly
captivating for its characters clues and
cry inducing resolution an absolute must
watch the autopsy of Jane Doe starring
Brian Cox and Emile Hirsch as Tommy and
Aston Tilden
the autopsy of Jane Doe brings in
frights and freakish encounters from the
get-go and doesn't let up until viewers
are totally spooked the father-son duo
in the film have an unusual bond they
both work as coroner's while that alone
is pretty strange things get far more
sinister when the Tilden's are delivered
the corpse of an unidentified woman one
that shows increasingly strange signs of
trauma who is this woman what happened
to her is she even dead the autopsy of
Jane Doe sizzles with an easiness and
oddities with a peppering of jump-scares
and gory slashings it's all bubbles over
into a climax you won't see coming
Justice League dark you might have been
too distracted by the blockbuster Marvel
and DC releases coming this year to see
Justice League dark which is a shame the
Warner Brothers bagged animated flick
offers up a refreshing angle on the
standard superhero storylines it blends
together razor-sharp wit and a lot of
screen time for everyone's favorite
trench-coated troublemaker John
Constantine as the title implies Justice
League dark is well much darker than
your typical comic-book movie it's got a
risk er rating from the MPAA and
adventures into new territory beyond the
stock Points fans have become almost soo
familiar with it maintains a quick pace
and sets up a spine-tingling whodunit
mystery but it doesn't rest on shock for
Chuck's sake or any fluff that falls
flat though Constantine's trademark
rapid-fire swearing is absent from the
film it's one that's absolutely worth a
watch now that you know it exists you're
welcome
the law though this perfectly odd polish
flicks on international release in 2015
it finally hit the States in February
2017 and it's hard to express how great
that is for film fans a mashup of
musical camp and horrorcore sprinkled
with classic movie monsters and vampire
summer Mase the law is wicked and weird
right down to its flippy fishtail what's
the premise you asked well its plot
centers around mermaid vampires turn
strippers who attempts to lead normal
lives even under the neon lights of a
nightclub but they're first for blood
sex and violence causes rifts in their
relationships and also hurts their
chances of staying stealthy the law is
deliciously dicey with its characters
and turns on a dime of its disjointed
scenes but that's what makes it so
gripping it's no teeny bopper aquamarine
dream that's for sure maybe you could
meet me in Fiji champagne xx if there's
two things horror filmmakers love its
anthologies and possessed children this
Sundance Film Festival gem brings
together both in a blood-boiling
marriage the brainchild of a group of
female directors including Saint Vincent
the indie rock guitar goddess her real
name is Annie Clark by the way x-axis
comprised two four.hoorah mini films the
short stories weave through familiar
relations of mother and son past
animalistic behaviors and inter mental
illnesses and the deep beiongs the grit
and gore of camping trips gone wrong XX
finds its strengths and its subtle
silliness while scary enough in their
own right the short tails are intercut
with haunting stop-motion cutscenes that
bring it all together but there's still
an element of Campina stew it it just
all works a monster cause looking at the
poster for a monster calls you might be
tempted to assume it's just another
young adult movie about a kid who hangs
around with a talking tree monster and
hey we already have the guardians of the
galaxy so who needs that the reality
however is far more complex and
compelling the film which saw a limited
release in 2016 before opening wide this
year tells the story of a 12 year old
boy are struggling to cope with his
mother's terminal illness while facing
bullies at school and a prickly
grandmother at home dark and honest in a
way that family-friendly features rarely
dare to be these days a monster cause
was perhaps destined to fall through the
cracks in theaters but it received heaps
of praise from critics for a reason
don't miss it to the bone minimalistic
but moving
the bone tells a tale of illness and
isolation it follows Ellen played by
Lily Collins a headstrong young woman
who's been grappling with anorexia for
most of her life enter dr. William
Beckham played by an impeccably cast
Keanu Reeves who runs an eccentric
wellness clinic and runs ellen past her
wit's end directed by buffy the vampire
slayer' writer producer Marti Noxon to
the bone is black comedy at its best and
the most beautiful full of crackling
humour and sharp tongued sarcasm Netflix
was so enamored with Noxon directorial
debut the streaming service snatched up
the rights to it back in January for a
cool eight million dollars soon you'll
have no excuse to miss it love song so
Jung Kim's love song that weaves a warm
account of two women on the cusp of
self-discovery Mindy and her best friend
Sarah embark on an impromptu road trip
and are soon confronted with emotions
they can't deny Kim's past credits
include incredibly introspective films
such as in between days for Ellen and
treeless Mountain and she brings the
same kind of intricate and intimate
details to this affecting drama love
song is a treat for your heart as much
as your eyes with its cozy pastel
palette and elegant landscape it'll
leave you breathless at even the
smallest moments 20th century women set
in 1979 this indie darling features an
eclectic cast of characters that
includes Anna Bening as liberal leftist
dorothea Greta Gerwig a spunky redhead
photographer Abbey and rebel without a
cause Julie portrayed by a rough around
the edges Elle Fanning these unique
women come together to help raise
Dorothea son wondering if you're happy
it's a great shirt cut to just being
depressed this dramedy written and
directed by Mike Mills as a
coming-of-age film that disregards age
altogether it brings to light the idea
that it's never too late to start over
start for the first time or start
believing you can begin in the first
place with an engaging slice of life
premise and pleasing honesty the film
herbs and flows organically just be sure
to have some tissues on hand since it's
pretty much guaranteed you'll get
misty-eyed
a United Kingdom amma asante sits in the
director's seat for this 1940's foray
into racial conflicts family ties and
political motivations in a time of high
tension and segregation David O yellow
and Rosamund
a star as an incumbent African King and
lily-white Londoner Ruth Williams the
pair falls deep and fast for one another
much to the chagrin of those around them
dodging attempts to break them apart and
prevent them from eloping the duo is
pushed to defy odds are never back down
from screenwriter Guy Hibbert a United
Kingdom is at once powerful and
appropriately uniting piloting through
the nooks and crannies of love and
liberty to present a roar accounts of
couple battling adversity though the
film does lean away from the gritty
elements of racism Hibbert crafts a
potent story that will leave any viewer
changed for the better
caddy next up on the list of films
you've missed is possibly the one you'll
be most bummed you didn't know existed
this is the Internet and as such cats
are worshipped as gods caddy is a
documentary about the feral cats of
Istanbul the filmmakers took to the
streets to introduce viewers to the free
roaming felines that lead surprisingly
unique lives and the people who are
interact with them on a daily basis
Kaddi features kittens with necks for
slipping into hidden alleyway crevices
cats that keep a keen eye on the dogs
for the incoming fish market shipments
and furry faced friends perched upon
doorsteps and behind shop counters it
can be silly on the surface but caddy
has a big heart and though it's centered
around animals the film's narrative
feels utterly human very much a part of
the local culture and the community of
Istanbul the cats and kittens of kettie
remind us that were not born knowing
hatred or judgments illustrated through
the remarkable respect between man and
animal plus adorable kittens what's not
to love
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]